وأنت مسيحي تجربة تلك
الطبيعة الأكثر صرامة ، كان من
المفترض أن تجري مقابلة مع
الرئيس الإيراني هناك في نيويورك في
الأمم المتحدة ، أخبرنا عن سبب عدم
حدوث ذلك بشكل جيد.
في نيويورك ، كان
قد أجرى بالفعل مقابلة في إيران
لمدة 60 دقيقة حيث كان الحجاب
يمثل مشكلة أيضًا ولكن هناك لأنه من
المعتاد أن يرتدي
المرء الحجاب دائمًا عندما يكون المرء هناك
لا يمكنك العمل
كصحفي.  هنا في نيويورك أو في أي مكان
آخر خارج إيران ، لم
يسألني أي رئيس إيراني ،
وقد أجريت مقابلات مع كل واحد
منهم منذ عام 1995 ، سواء داخل إيران أو خارجها ،
لم يُطلب منه أبدًا ارتداء
الحجاب بعد ساعات من الاستعداد لهذه
المقابلة.  إجراء محادثات مسبقة
مع مسؤولي الرئيس أو
إعطائهم نوعًا من فكرة عما
أردنا طرحه حول أه ليس أسئلة
واضحة ولكن فكرة يعرفونها exa  بالتأكيد
نريد التحدث عن الصفقة النووية
نريد التحدث عن دعم إيران
لروسيا ضد أوكرانيا والأهم من
ذلك أننا نريد التحدث عن
انتهاك حقوق الإنسان في
النهاية توصلوا إلى هذا ، تعلمون أنه
شهر حداد ديني
ونريدك أن ترتدي الحجاب وقد
رفضت بأدب شديد نيابة عني
وعن CNN والصحفيات في
كل مكان لأنه ليس
مطلبًا وقد تم إلقاؤنا علينا
في اللحظة الأخيرة
ولسوء الحظ قرروا سحب ما
تعرفونه  المقابلة ، لذا فهي
مشكلة وقد علمنا ، على
سبيل المثال ، أن وزير خارجية
السويد وآخرين تعرفهم برو ينتقدون
هذه الاحتجاجات وقمع القمع
العنيف لإيران ويقولون
إن حقوق المرأة هناك يجب أن
تُحترم كيف تقرأ هذا  كريستيان ،
هل تقرأ هذا على أنه
خوف مما يحدث في الشوارع
في إيران من الواضح أنه ليس خوفًا من رؤية
شعرك لأن هذا ليس ما يدور
حوله يبدو أنه  لم أرغب
في التحدث إليك بشأن ما
يحدث الآن في الشوارع جيدًا ،
لا يمكنني الحكم مسبقًا على ذلك لأنهم أخبرونا
أننا أجرينا المقابلة ، كان من
الصعب جدًا الحصول على المقابلة ،
ولا شك في ذلك والكثير  من
العمل ، أعتقد أنه إذا كان بإمكاني أن
أخمن فقط وكيف أقرأه ، أعتقد
أنه لا يريد أن يُرى مع
أنثى بدون حجاب في هذه
اللحظة
إما لأنه يسميه
شهرًا دينيًا أو لأن الناس يريدون  قولي
كيف يجلس مع
صحفي أجنبي تعرفينه لا
يرتدي الحجاب ومع ذلك داخل إيران
يقومان بقمع
الشابات اللواتي لا يرتدين
الحجاب ولكن حقيقة الأمر
هي أن النساء يرتدين الحجاب.
الحجاب أحيانًا احتجاجًا يخلعونه لكنهم
السلطات وأنا أعلم لأنني كنت
هناك ورأيته كل عام
يغيرون حدودهم وتعرف
حدودهم وحياتهم أحيانًا
ندبة الرأس  يجب أن يكون f هنا في بعض الأحيان ، فلا
بأس إذا كنت هنا ، فأنت لا
تعرف أبدًا ما هي المعايير
وقد سقطت هؤلاء النساء في هذا السؤال ، ولا
بد لي من السماح لك بالذهاب إلى هنا ينفد
من الوقت ولكن بسرعة كبيرة عندما
ترى تلك الاحتجاجات  أعتقد أن
هناك ميلًا للناس ليقولوا ،
هذه المرة سيكون الأمر مختلفًا
، لست متأكدًا من ذلك ، عندما تقول
مختلفًا ، يقول بعض الأشخاص الذين أعرفهم في
الخارج ، هل هذه هي النهاية هذه
ثورة مضادة ولكني  لا أعتقد
أن هذا هو الحال ، لا أعتقد أن
الأرقام موجودة وأنا
أعلم لأنني جربتها بنفسي على سبيل المثال
في عام 2009 أن النظام لديه كل
القوة وسوف يتخذ إجراءات صارمة للغاية